It is I cookie Magneto what the f I'm not engaging
this guy that's hardly up to you Rick
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my full Rick
and Morty season six episode eight video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and careful for spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll just start at
the beginning work our way through shop by shot
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments as we go
along starting with the episode title analyze piss
which is a reference to the Robert De Niro movie
Analyze This who gets help from a psychiatrist
played by Billy Crystal which is similar to the
plot of the episode where Rick goes to therapy
with Dr Wong who comes back and tries to figure
out what's going on with the pissmaster villain
who is voiced by Will Forte who did an amazing
job he's probably one of the funniest Cameo
scenes this season oh cheers I got my ass whipped
made me realize people just want to see me fail
the opening scene is another battle that Rick and
Morty are having with Mr Nimbus who comes back to
take his Island base which is very apropos because
Mr is a very direct reference to Marvel's Namor we
just saw Namor in live action in Black Panther
wakanda forever when Mr Nimbus takes off and he
splashes water on himself that's also a reference
to namor's strength increasing when he's wet or
touching water this is a big plot point during
wakanda forever he's about as strong as Captain
America when he's totally dry but when he's wet
or in water he becomes about as strong as the
Hulk the oil tanker spill feels like an Exxon
Valdez reference one of the worst oil tanker
spills in history until Rick would rather destroy
his base rather than give it to Mr Nimbus because
he's starting to get tired of fighting all these
villains like I'm getting tired of this we need
to go home all part of the idea that he's become
a magnet for these low-level super villains which
are sort of a metaphor for online trolls the whole
episode is basically like Rick and Morty versus
online trolling online bullying you notice he's
got his old spaceship back I'm assuming he just
rebuilt this one the next super villain cookie
Magneto obviously a version of Magneto from the
Marvel Comics the colors that he's wearing make
his costume seem a little bit more like hyperion's
costume he's like Marvel's version of Superman
but but because we're going with the whole Magneto
joke his powers are controlling cookies things
that are called cookies even if they aren't
actually cookies and cookie ingredients the
joke there is that he's supposed to be super
overpowered because he can control sugar which is
literally in every living thing so technically he
should be able to control all biological life
on the earth in the argument with Morty is just
a reference to all the comic book jokes about
characters Powers being completely off the rails
and unexplained Rick makes a tick reference which
is a reference to all the ridiculous villains and
heroes inside the universe of the tick comic
books in the TV shows they're really crazy in
the 90s style goofball reference is another X-Men
90s reference because in the 90s X-Men were like
the most popular comic book in the world you also
started to see a lot of edgier a lot of weirder a
lot of crazier villains and heroes show up
in the comics during this period the whole
thing about him punching down is also part of the
theme of the episode like the piss Master villain
that they have to deal with is a metaphor for an
online troll as are the other low-level villains
they all harass Rick which doesn't seem like a
huge deal just super annoying Rick doesn't want
to deal with it he usually would punch down to
get rid of them in real life this is a metaphor
for online trolls going after popular posts or
celebrities and the celebrities with like really
big accounts punching down metaphorically on these
like little tiny accounts trying to get a reaction
out of them which is basically the message that Dr
Wong gives Rick later like oh the best thing you
can do is just not respond to them so that's why
I say the episode is kind of like Rick and Morty
versus online trolls online bullying Mr Calypso is
a reference to Mr mix's pit lick from the Superman
comics he's a fifth dimensional imp like this
James Gunn also recently canonized bat-mite to the
DCU on The Peacemaker series he's another fifth
dimensional imp just like Mr Mxyzptlk who stans
Batman and just bugs him all the time I'd rather
be with bat-mite than you it's a bad way it's
a two foot tall interdimensional imp who stans
Batman I'd rather be with him really good example
to this online trolls metaphor in the episode is
when Mr Kalypso shows up he just says mean thing
things to upset Rick doesn't actually do anything
to hurt him during the intro scene they confirmed
that this scene of Jerry in the armor suit on the
council is real technically in last week's episode
because Rick traveled through the fourth wall
with Morty in the actual credits all the intro
scenes were in an actual episode but you get the
idea when Rick jokes about not shooting Batman and
his Bat logo that's another bat might reference
because he's the same type of imp we also learned
that Rick is milking Calypso for his Cosmic fluid
from his higher Dimension so we'll see if he winds
up using that for something sounds like it's
going to be super powerful but the joke about
him profiting from The Exchange from him dealing
with the super villain trolls is a reference to
real life celebrities in brands profiting from
online trolls and hate posting like people posting
incendiary things trying to get a rise out of
people just to profit off of it which Jerry also
winds up doing eventually like he eventually winds
up profiting off of being a literal social justice
Warrior they reference the events of pickle Rick
again and reveal that he also tried the exact same
trick later by by turning himself into a housefly
which they pay off later in the episode when he
does it to Mr goldenfold his master shows up
to harass them he's meant to be their version
of Green Goblin because of the glider and because
of the greenish kind of yellowish color too he's
played by Will Forte probably one of the funniest
Cameo scenes from a celebrity that I've seen this
season Jerry complains about his bees again they
made a couple more Bees references in this episode
they've done a lot this season Jerry's bees have
become a really big plot point he makes a golden
shower reference talking to Summer there are
actually a couple references to that in this
episode the real joke here though is that he's
just a troll Who's down and out on his luck like
he's basically harmless because Jerry is able to
go toe-to-toe with him pound for pound that's how
weak and pathetic he is he isn't an actual super
villain he's just trying to get a rise out of them
when they're fighting around the neighborhood
though we find out that Gene has a wife I don't
think we've ever seen her before the kid behind
him is wearing a 69 Jersey nice at breakfast the
next day they're eating strawberry smiggles from
interdimensional cable I actually bought some
of those in real life they were selling limited
edition versions a couple years ago like actual
strawberry smiggles breakfast cereal you could
buy summer makes a bunch of Twitter jokes there's
been a ton of those recently because Elon Musk
just bought Twitter there's no reference to that
specifically in the episode like just general
Twitter jokes because they wrote the episode
a long time ago The Jezebel reference is a
real-life caddy website that posts a lot of
celebrity tell-all stories and hit pieces like the
one that Beth references Rick's gun that he pulls
out is the fake one that he used back during
season three him using it when the orbs come
is because he only plans on using it for General
intimidation like he doesn't actually plan to kill
them because he thinks they're just more harmless
trolls that have shown up to harass them the
aliens are meant to be a very obvious reference
to the Green Lantern core the one with the giant
head is specifically a reference to the Owens like
the council is their version of the Owen Council
from the Green Lantern Comics who invite Jerry to
join their Justice Council which is more of a DC
Justice League Green Lantern reference but also a
social justice Warrior reference like he becomes a
literal and metaphorical so social justice Warrior
going around stopping trolls Across the Universe
their orbs are like their Green Lantern ring so
he's like a version of Hal Jordan on the series
getting a Green Lantern ring when Rick says he
was banned from the next door app if you don't
live in the United States or you don't own a
house next door is like a niche social media
site just for groups that live on the same blocks
so the idea is that all of Rick's neighbors kicked
him off of the app summer gets really specific
when talking about the golden shower making it
sound like she secretly freaky like that like she
knows about them from experience then we learned
the orb works like the Green Lantern rings The
Twist being he can only control mundane things
like it doesn't do a whole lot the only difference
here is that Rick is the one to make him his super
suit which I think is meant to set up the twist
with him creating the super suit for pissmaster
but it's more of an Iron Man type of suit with
the orb acting like an arc reactor powering it
the way he uses the orb though is just like the
Green Lantern comics in the movies with the Green
Lantern rings telling them about distressed
beacons Across the Universe finding a space
Hitler group to take down the space Hitler group
is meant to be a reference to the Legion of Doom
from the DC Comics they have the brain who has
a little Hitler stash painted on his boat like
they're all Hitler themed even though a lot of
them are comic book villains this is Gorilla Grodd
this is a version of The Riddler and it looks like
they have an actual Hitler like an old man Hitler
because he just lived to present day on the team
the banner in the background also reminded me of
the Star Trek Mirror Universe Empire's Banner in
this whole scene of him taking them down is the
scene from the intro the news broadcast font that
they use here on the chirons make this feel like
a CNN parody the person on the left is actually
voiced by Dan Harmon he's usually in most of the
episodes playing at least some small character in
the background I think this app is meant to be an
Instagram reference and it's supposed to be Beth's
account because Summer is commenting on the post
but zoom in enhance the girl above her commenting
with the hearts is her friend that keeps wanting
to bang Jerry she was also in the last episode
of the funeral really sad because she didn't get
to bang Jerry before he was killed by his bees
squanchy is also commenting on the post so we're
wondering when he's going to come back in a bigger
way there's even another bee creature this horny
on main for him which is just another joke about
Jerry being obsessed with bees they have another
joke about Mr Goldenfold's therapy his big thing
was corporaphagia which is literally eating poop
they made a reference to that earlier this season
turning him into a fly also call back to the
housefly joke earlier the funny thing here too is
that Mr goldenfold claims that being turned into a
fly cured all of his problems my therapy is done I
don't need any more also secretly foreshadows Rick
wanting to help pissmaster like secretly being a
good person at heart and wanting to help people
like he didn't want to hurt Mr goldenfold he
actually wanted to help him like here this cures
all your problems you're fine get out of here
Jerry goes to a breakfast-themed planet where
like the entire planet is made up of breakfast
themed creatures the bread going after the eggs
is like your breakfast literally fighting with
itself the space Mitsubishi reference is meant
to pay off Rick's joke about profiting off of
all this online troll Behavior being a social
justice Warrior like Jerry is starting to become
the villain he's starting to enjoy the power and
the money that's being given to him by being a
social justice Warrior so he's slowly turning
into a bully himself also they might have had an
integration with Mitsubishi cars in real life and
that might be why they use the name Mitsubishi
so specifically like why Mitsubishi probably
because Mitsubishi cars in real life paid Rick
and Morty a ton of money to be mentioned in an
episode I'm not sure who the rhyming string bean
villain is supposed to be a reference to Solomon
Grundy Rhymes in the comics but he doesn't look
anything like Grundy Dr buckles actually feels
like more of a lobo DC reference then Rick feels
sorry for pissmaster because now he's the one
that's being bullied by everyone goes to his house
to make amends and finds that he's killed himself
because of all the bullying blaming Jerry for
everything he finds out that he's divorced he
used to be this standout guy he's got all these
medals these Awards but he's living in squalor
basically he's down and out on his luck he tries
to spare his daughter's feelings then redeems him
in the Public's Eyes by pretending to be him doing
all these heroic acts the Montage of him building
his suit is meant to be a reference to Iron Man
in the first Iron Man movie building the mark
1. all the bottles of piss lying around his room
feel like a Howard Hughes reference but also he's
pissmaster he uses it for fuel and for weapons and
I love how specific they get with the character
like the bottles are toilet themed everything
about him is piss themed I can't wait to see
some kid walking through a toy store saying mommy
mommy buy me the piss toy they have a bunch more
piss jokes golden god golden shower jokes a joke
about not missing as in not missing the toilet
bowl the music they play is like a piss-themed
version of jock jams and the whole bomb plot you
probably recognized is the one from Dark Knight
Rises like they basically borrowed it from that
with Batman making everyone think that he died by
flying the bomb away from the city he gets into
the fight with Jerry who comes to invite him to
their version of the Green Lantern Corps he makes
a Michael Crichton Andromeda strained reference
and then when the aliens show up they kick Jerry
out after they find out about Rick thinking that
he'd been piss Master the whole time and they were
just pulling some weird scheme it wishes another
reference to people profiting off of all the
social justice warring and online trolling like
people who start a lot of fights online just for
the purposes of profiting from it there was like
a whole era of YouTube background 2016 when that
started to happen we call it like the edge core
era of YouTube that's when they started hardcore
Banning channels for doing really really bad
stuff and they sort of demonetizing a lot of
channels the whole joke about the family ignoring
the obvious continuity errors when he says that he
was pissmaster the whole time is also just a comic
book joke about continuity not making sense if you
look back long enough summer also makes an Avatar
movie reference we're getting Avatar 2 really soon
in theaters in all of Rick's Goodwill is undone
when he can't keep it inside and shows Morty
the note the whole joke there is they were only
praising him because they thought it was a noble
sacrifice getting beat up by Jerry just to make
him feel better but it was only a noble sacrifice
as long as Rick kept the secret during the
post-credits scene they revealed the Green Lantern
Council votes on replacement members they make the
Scarlett Johansson reference because of the Marvel
movies she played Black Widow know and agree that
it'll be Mr Nimbus Rick's Nemesis the joke about
his reps saying that he's busy now is a Marvel
Studios Kevin feige joke like Kevin feige won't
let them use Namor on their Green Lantern Council
because they have the rights to the character it
actually felt like a pretty short episode even
though it's meant to be the same length as all
the other episodes but if you spotted any other
Easter eggs or references that I didn't talk about
during the video just write them Below in the
comments in my full episode 9 video we'll post
next week after they release it everyone click
here for my new Ant-Man 3 Kang video and click
here for my new Green Lantern video speak of the
devil a lot of Green Lantern references in this
episode thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!